let's do some audience questions start
with wall-e while he says hey David how
realistic is the National popular vote
interstate compact to ever happen so I
should first explain what that is
NPV I see as I know at national popular
vote interstate compact it's basically
an idea where without actually
abolishing the electoral college you
could make it so that the winner of the
popular vote would be the President of
the United States and the way it would
happen is if you can get enough states
whose sum total of elux electoral votes
is 272 agree that no matter how their
state votes they will award their
electoral votes to the winner of the
popular vote nationally you effectively
have a national popular vote it wouldn't
require changing the constitution it
wouldn't require three-quarters of the
states and two-thirds of the House and
Senate or whatever it is exactly that
would have to happen now in order to
change the electoral college
it would just require enough individual
states such that they add up to 270
electoral votes to agree that they will
ignore the popular vote result of their
state in awarding their electoral votes
and award them based on the popular vote
of the country how likely is it let me
say it into two sort of different ways I
think it's more likely that we would
have the NPV I see then we would have
the formal elimination of the electoral
college
yeah as part of the Constitution I think
that's not gonna happen
I think the NPV I see is more likely
than that I agree ratifying a 28th
amendment very very difficult not gonna
happen probably not gonna happen
however I still don't know that the NPV
I see is super likely I mean that we
we've reported on this off and on and
there's some interest in it and you've
had some sort of conditional interest
from states and I would be very very
much for it I want to be super clear I
don't you know and being pragmatic I
wish I could say something like within
12 years we will have a fully
implemented NPV I see I I just don't
really think we don't have that and the
problem is I mean the electoral college
versus the
popular vote is a very significant
political issue I mean it's cost
Democrats what two out of the past five
elections yeah Al Gore should have been
president and Hillary Clinton even argue
should have been president if we went by
the popular vote right but once the
election is over no one pays attention
to it anymore and if you wait too long
then you get into the heat of the next
election cycle and then it's like well I
mean it's a little bit too late to
consider this now we're already
campaigning in certain states that's
sort of like the voter ID and voter
suppression stuff where there's always
more and more interest as we get closer
and closer to the election and then
lawsuits on Election Day and then people
sort of forget about it and that's why I
try to talk about it even in between
elections because it is a really
important issue so I would be very much
interested in the npv I see I think it's
a super interesting project how
realistic is it
it's totally realistic it's just not
that likely I guess I answer Wally and I
mean Democrats have won six out of the
last seven popular vote content that's
right so it would be good for Democrats
but it's also it's good for democracy
yeah I think you can certainly argue
that yeah I mean I've said before the
problem with the electoral college is
part of the idea of it was to prevent
elected candidates to prevent candidates
not elected officials from spending all
their time just in big cities because
that's where the big populations are but
all it's done is make it so that they
never go to those big cities and instead
they just spend their time in a handful
of swing states right so it's it's just
refocused where they are but it doesn't
make it so that candidates are all over
the country yeah now we have television
we have the internet so where you go for
a speech doesn't matter as much as it
did before
absolutely so there it is Wally wish I
had better news for you